first thing first you know back in
middle school when they taught us
it was three branches of the government
we forgot it when we got older
rapper yellow pain breaks down the
united states government in his now
viral song my vote don't count and
encourages people
to vote despite the belief that voting
does not create real change now with the
remix called
my vote will count leaving many more
educated
on the government system yellow pain
how are you doing going on i'm doing
awesome it's
not lost on me that the reason your song
has been shared countlessly and viewed
over 1.8 million times on youtube
alone is because of how real the
sentiments that you actually shared are
especially in the black community
what made you think that the message
that you shared would be received
differently
this time my cousin came to me and she
was trying to tell me like you should
make a song about voting because i'm
like cuz i love you but i'm cool i'm not
into politics you know what i mean it's
not an interest of mine but she broke it
down to me and
she broke it down to me so well and i
just had this wake up moment and i was
like wow cuz so you mean to tell me that
the reason why i set up like this and
why this is like this and like this is
like this
because we don't vote and i just felt a
passion at that point you talk about
your cousin
she's running for congress in ohio yeah
and that's what we see at the end of the
music video
exactly yeah my cousin desiree tim she's
running for congress in the 10th
district of ohio
so every time you sit out an election
every time you don't show up
because you think it doesn't matter
someone else is happy that you didn't
show up
what especially about what she was
saying hit you the most
when she broke it down to me she asked
me why do you feel like your vote
doesn't matter and you know i was
explaining to her
the same misconception that a lot of
people that i know have it's just that
you know i voted for obama back in 2016.
i was looking for change
nothing happened you know i was still
struggling my family was still
struggling and i felt like
you know it was it was nothing else that
was done she mentioned different
specific issues and those
issues were like the ones that i named
at the end of the song
i said imagine life on the other side
grows better
school's better everybody get their
license back grocery store food better
custody of your kids back homeless
people get new shelters if we gonna fix
the us
we gotta start with them two letters me
and you issues like that are the type of
issues that are fixed
you know my everyday life and the people
in my community there's a street in my
city that's called salem avenue and
they've been doing construction on this
street
for years and and when i tell you it's
like one of the most important streets
in the city you know everybody is
complaining
if we vote we can actually get somebody
in congress that can pass a law
you know that can get that sped up so
when the news station tried to tell us
that barack obama couldn't put a song
we was all saudi at obama when it was
the congress members all along
you rap about the focus that everybody
has on
just the president right and for that
same reason there are people right now
who are on the fence about voting
believe it or not
because of this whole well i don't know
about this candidate i don't know about
this candidate
what do you say to a person who's still
on the fence
right now i would tell them i was you
you know i would tell them
not too long ago i felt the same way i
felt like
you know everything was in the
president's hand and that it you know my
vote didn't count
but at the end of the day we have to
take some level of
the responsibility and executive but all
we know is the executive that's the
mayor
or the governor and the president now
you take
some really important and tough issues
to discuss
and you put in a rap song that makes
everybody kind of
want to move and get engaged and you're
kind of reprimanding us
but i'm willing to hear it how easy or
hard was it to take such
strong and tough issues and just
simplify them in a rap song
i think i understand why poor people and
you know what i'm saying low-income
communities like why we don't
vote as much is because i think the
lingo is just a little bit overwhelming
and i thought it was going to be so easy
i went to write the song
and then by the time i got to the second
half of the song mind you i'm coming
from somebody who previously
didn't know nothing about politics and i
know a little bit of information at this
point
i was writing it was like judicial
legislative executive and i was using
all these big words and then
i pulled back i was like oh wow i sound
like one of the people
that i was complaining about it took a
while to write the song i had to
it took a lot to simplify
she's a super dope singer we wanted to
make the song even more fun
and even more youthful so we wanted to
get you know a beautiful voice on it
and it was like 7th street was the best
possible person for it and
in that same remix you joined forces
with vote.org
in an effort to get more people to the
voting polls
a lot of people don't want to vote the
world won't be changed in on november
3rd you know but we have to make sure
that
we respect voting as much as we do a
holiday let's make election day
the new christmas let's get dressed get
fly
go down to the polls and make sure we
stay on top of the candidates because
that way we can potentially have a
better future
[Music]